hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast there is a rightful
vitamin-d a global perspective presented
by our keynote presenter Michael
assholic PhD in Z professor of medicine
physiology and biophysics director of
the general Clinical Research Unit and
director of the bone health care clinic
I am the director of Helio therapy light
and skin Research Center at Boston
University Medical Center I am Cristina
mahalik of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
lab with is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left or the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen dr. Holick will be
following up with your with you via
email please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know when you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits and will be available
for on-demand viewing through February
of 2018 please click on the button in
the bottom left corner and saw the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Holick I will
now turn the presentation over to our
speaker
hello I'm Michael Holick and I'm gonna
be giving you a very broad overview
about vitamin D and hopefully convince
you that this is a delightful hormone
now I know I was in trouble because how
what am I going to tell you about
vitamin D that you don't already know
about well one thing you may not be
aware of is guess what worms need
vitamin D and I'll tell you that at the
end of the story so I have this varied
audience and I know you have a wide
range of experiences so I wondered how I
could really get this message across so
I went to a higher authority a doctor
that I think you all know and respect
for his wisdom and I asked him for some
advice and this is what he told me
you're an idiot and so basically he's
saying that I'm an idiot because what am
I going to tell you about vitamin D
there you don't already know about from
the Institute of Medicine report well it
turns out that the IOM came out with its
recommendations in 2010 and they're
really quite remarkable because they
realized that the 200 units that was
originally thought all that we needed
that now most children adults these 600
units a day and more importantly they
recognized that it was important that
you also vitamin D is not as toxic as we
once thought and that easily 4,000 units
a day for older children and adults is
perfectly safe so when I think about
this and I'm always asked by the press
what do I think about it I have one word
for it Wow there's never been a nutrient
that has been increased triple overnight
but the real question is did they get it
right and indeed in 2011 The Endocrine
Society came out with its
recommendations and all of the members
on this committee are experts in the
field of vitamin D and I was honored to
chair this committee and our objective
was clear and that is to help treat and
prevent vitamin D deficiency and for the
care of patients the Institute of
medicines goal was different it was used
a population model and expected medical
societies to make recommendations for
prevention and treatment which is what
the endocrine society did and indeed it
turns out that the recommendations for
infants is four hundred to a thousand
units a day children six hundred to a
thousand units
des and adults 1,500 to 2,000 units a
day and if you're obese you need two to
three times more vitamin D and so it
turns out that people worry about
conflict of interest so I do get support
from NIH and I consult for a variety of
companies but much to the dismay the
dermatology community I get support from
the Sun and for those that are
registered you can go to this website
dr. Holick com for more information now
I have been talking about vitamin D for
more than 40 years and people could not
think of a more boring subject than
vitamin D found Kyle the Royal prevents
rickets and children we don't see
rickets commonly we're not thinking
about vitamin D deficiency so what is
she thinking about well who is at risk
and hopefully convince you that everyone
is he's worried about global warming No
what is the big deal about vitamin D
deficiency because really rickets is the
tip of the iceberg
because many chronic illnesses and bone
diseases like osteomalacia and diabetes
multiple sclerosis rheumatoid arthritis
infectious diseases hypertension heart
disease even common cancers have all
been associated with vitamin D
deficiency
indeed Discover Magazine and O 7
suggested over the top 100 medical
breakthroughs number eight came in can
vitamin D save your life
Time magazine same year 10 biggest
medical breakthroughs more health
benefits of vitamin D now we're always
taught of course to publish in the major
medical journals No here a fitness
magazine is a super vitamin and if you
want to get your teenagers attention
there's only one place to publish Teen
Vogue and in fact it's been the problem
that the doctors weren't getting it it
would be the lay public that would go to
the doctor saying please get me my blood
level but the doctor would refuse
patient persist and now the doctors got
religion because finds that the
patient's vitamin D deficient the a
se425 at Roxy D is the most ordered
esoteric assay now in the United States
and one in nine Australian see but now
have a blood level drawn so vitamin D is
a sunshine vitamin and so I wondered
about these dark hair in E and earth
all's how they could have survived in
the northern European climate and it
turns out that they DNA has now
jested that they were red-headed at
celtic the driver and evolution is clear
for hyperpigmentation you see on this
pelvis of a normal female and this
pelvis of a female that likely had in
the tile rickets she would have had it
difficult if not an impossible time with
childbirth thing so within a few
generations pigmentation disappeared
devolved in order to produce enough
vitamin D now we showed many years ago
you can't make any vitamin D in Boston
in a winter time so I took my daughter
on safari to Kenya so we could write it
off on our taxes and medical expense
doesn't work
however this sampler warrior is
perfectly designed for his environment
so how do you really compare and
contrast so I figured there's no
question that my gene pigment devolved
in order to enhance vitamin D production
and so how do you make vitamin D when
you're exposed to sunlight it's the
precursor 700 cholesterol and your skin
absorbs ultraviolet radiation converting
at the vitamin D now you have to wonder
about can you make too much vitamin D
from excessive exposure she's got a lot
of bad habits but one thing you don't
have to worry about you will never
become toxic and the reason is that any
excess is destroyed by the Sun now I'm
always asked the question sunlight
versus supplement doesn't make any
difference in terms of how the body
reacts to it and he's a poster child of
course for sun exposure and yes when you
make it in your skin it lasts two to
three times longer for you mrs. story
because in Industrial Revolution these
kids in these alleyways not exclude any
sunlight throughout classic rickets
growth retardation and the skeletal
abnormalities it was to physicians in
New York City
1921 that demonstrated that they could
cure rickets simply by exposing him to
sunlight this led to a novel concept our
government set up an agency in 1931
sending out this brochure telling
parents to send your children outside
expose them to sensible sun exposure to
prevent them from getting rickets but in
fact they patented this concept back in
the 1930s mommy will I make enough
vitamin D but of course now everybody
worries about skin cancer and so for 40
years really unchallenged I've been the
mythologist telling you never to be
exposed to one direct ray of sunlight in
fact if you ever put your child outside
without a sunscreen here at least in the
United States you could wind up on
America's most wanted for child abuse
indeed this is the problem cows don't
put vitamin D in milk right it was hairy
Steinbach in Wisconsin in the 1920s that
realized if you can radiate people in
animals why not irradiate the food that
led to the magical Steinbach vitamin D
process the fortification of milk with
vitamin D and it essentially eradicated
rickets but the problem is of course in
this day and age do you know why vitamin
D is so tightly regulated worldwide most
European countries do not permit you to
buy a vitamin D supplement
over-the-counter and in South America
and in Asia it's the same issue why so
it turns out that you might think that
this had always been the case not true
it turns out that before 1950 many
products throughout Europe were being
fortified with vitamin D here in this
case custard even in Chicago hot dogs
were being fortified with vitamin D and
so yes it turned out that around 1950
Europe forbid vitamin D fortification of
milk why the reason is in the 1950s a
few infants presented with high blood
calcium altered faces mental retardation
and heart problems
the experts were brought in because they
had no clue what was going on and they
said yes pregnant rats who get high
doses of vitamin D their pups have high
blood calcium funny altered faces and
heart problems so they concluded the
most likely reason for this problem was
over fortification of milk with vitamin
D and as a result Europe banned
fortification not only of milk but of
all products that these regulations are
still on the books today throughout most
of Europe and most of the world and so
as a result neonatal hypercalcemia
banned the over fortification of milk
but likely these children had Williams
syndrome a rare genetic disorder
associated with funny faces
and heart problems mental retardation
and a hypersensitivity to vitamin D
causing hypercalcemia but unfortunately
this band continues to this day so
vitamin D is essential for bone health
so I thought I'd bring in a couple of
cases that you may not typically see in
your own practice this seven month old
female muscle weakness seizures calcium
of half normal turns out it's the first
lowland gorilla born in captivity at our
zoo in Boston and it turned out that it
was just about to die seen by
pediatrician given for her two units of
vitamin D didn't do any good and
concluded this infant had some rare
genetic disorder nothing we could do and
wish the caretaker good luck well it
turns out that baby's complaining her
mom got bone shaking dad's upset he
knows his daughters in deep trouble have
you ever wonder what he was trying to
say this is what he was trying to say
indeed finally they suggested that I get
to see the infant and mom said to call
me and the infant has classic widen
epiphany or plates classic for vitamin D
deficiency so how do you treat
aggressively so I gave the infant five
thousand units of vitamin D a day and
the infant's feeling great in fact I was
the guest of honor for her first
birthday what's the message mommy well
my grows be stunted when you went to the
zoo to see her for a first few years of
life her growth was stunted because of
her in utero in her first few weeks of
life of vitamin D deficiency why should
you care because we still estimate more
than 50% of infants born even in the
United States but worldwide are born in
a deficient or insufficient State 1889
in Boston rickets was common so is this
a problem today with all of modern
medicine you better believe it we see
about a dozen cases a year at our
Hospital why because it's naive concept
out there that human breast milk will
provide the infant with all of his or
her nutritional requirement it will not
there is essentially no vitamin D in
human breast milk so if you give your
infant human breast milk because the
sole source of nutrition that infant
will be vitamin D deficient for that
period of time I'm not sure what she's
thinking about
but we asked a question at a hospital or
pregnant women at risk if they're taking
a pre
vitamin and we asked the question that
if they're at risk and we looked at 40
mother-infant pairs and measured vitamin
D status and demonstrated that they were
taking 600 units of vitamin D a day the
amount recommended by the Institute of
Medicine for all adults including
pregnant and lactating women and we went
out to show 76 percent of moms 81
percent of newborns were vitamin D
deficient why should you care because we
showed with Lisa Bodnar preeclampsia is
associated with vitamin D deficiency and
in fact again early pregnancy and
vitamin D status and risk it's not so
much taking it after you started the
pregnancy but it's really important to
have vitamin D on board early in
pregnancy to help reduce risk for
preeclampsia and indeed preeclampsia is
lowest when your blood levels pregnant
women are about 40 to 50 nanograms per
ml right so who are they these are three
children born by cesarean section back
in 1889 in Glasgow Scotland
why because mom had a flat deformed
pelvis because of infantile rickets and
so it turns out that also vitamin D is
particularly important for proximal
muscle week for muscle function and
that's important for birthing and so we
went on to show and over 200 women in
our Hospital that if their vitamin D
sufficient at the time they give birth
they have a 400 percent reduced risk of
requiring a cesarean section right and
so I'm not sure what Christina is
thinking about but we recommend all
pregnant women should be on 2,000 units
of vitamin D a day in fact maternal
vitamin D insufficiency early turns out
that if you're greater than 40 nanograms
per ml 60% lower preterm birth risk
that's quite remarkable indeed
gestational age was a function of 25
hydroxy vitamin D 60% reduction
premature births if 20 dr. D was greater
than 40 nanograms per ml and you'll be
hearing more about this also from dr.
Halas in his presentation
so how much do lactating women need
Hollis and Wagner showed very nicely
6000 units of vitamin D a day was put
enough vitamin D in their milk to
satisfy their infants requirement
pediatricians have been paranoid about
worrying about vitamin D toxicity and so
indeed how much do they need and when
should they beginning it and the
messages from the American Academy of
Pediatrics from birth and it should be
400 units of vitamin D a day in Canada
they recommend up to 800 units a day
pregnant lactating women 2,000 units a
day when you're all female muscle
weakness bony deformities inferior
thrive if you've heard of this so-called
the jurassic syndrome it turns out that
because of Steven Spielberg in Jurassic
Park that about 750,000 young in the
United States at risk well let us the
quickest on a healthy diet and it's not
because of people eating crickets it's
because of iguanas because the kids that
saw Jurassic Park wanted to have a pet
dinosaur and what better animal I have
done iguana
so about 750,000 or import United States
every year they're given a steady diet
of lettuce there's no calcium or vitamin
D and they wind up with osteoporosis and
osteomalacia they fresher the rib cages
they're long bones they fall off the
perches and they die well my
nine-year-old daughter went to see
Jurassic Park with me if she wanted a
pet iguana I couldn't have a pet iguana
died of a calcium and vitamin D
deficiency so what do you do keep up
with the literature and the reptile
literature says metabolic bone disease
this is what happens when your vitamin D
deficient increases risk for vertebral
fractures now I give a lot of
presentations to doctors and show a
patient like this nobody cares but
you'll remember that vitamin D
deficiency increases risk of vertebral
fractures and non vertebral fractures so
now what to do how do you treat it well
just like for our patients how do you
get them to take their calcium well I
gave it some milk no it gave it a
calcium supplement No
so he's not foaming at the mouth he's
getting low-fat cream cheese in between
the lettuce so he's getting all the
calcium that he needs
there's no vitamin D in low-fat cream
cheese so what to do
well they'd like to be outside cuz they
make lots of vitamin D so you know hatin
soup rises to the occasion when the
opportunity is there you can go to your
local pet shop and buy rep the Sun for
40 bucks that mimics sunlight so that
your pet reptile at home will make
vitamin D in the skin leaders were no
single residents know but we will do
this for our pet iguana
so there he is smart going to me because
I just spent 40 dollars so they could
make some vitamin D in his skin
so a very happy daughter with a happy
iguana and you need calcium and vitamin
D for strong bones and healthy teeth and
when you do that both my daughter and
her iguana grew very well six month old
twins muscle weakness bony deformities
and failure to thrive major PR problem
in Denver Colorado
these poor polar bears couldn't move
they thought that they might have some
type of newer muscular dystrophy but it
turns out that most likely the proximal
muscle weakness associated with vitamin
D deficiency and recommended adequate
vitamin D and a little bit of vitamin D
and tender love and care and they are
doing great also five year old female
poor dentition dental caries and delayed
tooth eruption major health issue for
non-human primates but it also turns out
that dental caries of course is
extremely common infectious disease and
children and studies have shown inverse
relationship with maternal 25 hydroxy
vitamin D and the amount of decay in
their infants in their first couple
years of life also periodontitis is a
major health issue and a study done here
at the dental school showed a strong
association with the higher your levels
of 25 hydroxy vitamin D lower is your
risk for periodontal disease for a
couple from Indonesia they relocated to
Washington DC and had non viable
offspring a major PR problem decades ago
because when sukarno visited Nixon he
brought with him a made a pair of Komodo
dragons there were no Komodo dragons in
any zoo in the United States and so they
figured that they would make and that it
would have lots of baby Komodo dragons
but they were non viable hatchlings I
happened to be in Washington DC and they
called me over to the zoo to ask because
I'm an endocrinologist that maybe they
have some kind of
problem I said well they do but not the
kind you're thinking about they're in a
glass enclosure and they likely are not
they're not making any vitamin D and
therefore likely vitamin D deficient and
I T determine that carefully and have
you treated equally carefully and sure
enough we went out to show in the
enclosure they can't make any vitamin D
and we gave vitamin D to both mom and
dad and they all had wonderful
hatchlings the next go-around in fact it
turns out that they need vitamin D so
it's true vitamin D deficiency is
associated with infertility low birth
weight and poor birth outcomes
indeed this study done in Dubai showed
vitamin D deficiency linked to
infertility so a minute music consultant
because I consult for many zoos still in
United States because this continues to
be a health issue so is it true that
vitamin D is rare in foods you would
think with a healthy diet you don't have
to worry
but with Carolyn Moore we showed many
years ago that no child or adult in the
United States could get enough vitamin D
from diet alone why is the Karen smush
room because mushrooms have the capacity
to make vitamin D so sun dried mushrooms
have a good source of vitamin D but back
in the 40s and 50s right kids line up
for cod liver oil and because it tasted
so good right we don't do this anymore
and it comes in tablet and it comes in
oil it comes in emulsion and you realize
by now a little bit controversial now my
stance a sensible sun exposure
constantly interviewed by the press but
the dermatologist said now just eat more
fish well how much fish do you have to
eat it's not a pretty sight right indeed
this is my son we go sail fishing in
Guatemala catch release program they
don't have any these rooster fish there
in ebony it's only oily fish salmon
mackerel herring how much you have to
eat you'd have to eat it every day
there's only about 500 to a thousand
units but that's not the question to ask
the question to ask is are you eating
farmed versus wild caught salmon because
we showed farm salmon have only about 10
to 25% of the vitamin D content compared
to wild caught salmon so this is where
we're getting our vitamin D from from
casual not so Catholics
the sunlight summertime feeling great
making lots of vitamin D sun's coming
through the ozone layer directly and
you're making vitamin D but in
wintertime the Sun is come in at a more
black angle and the question is can you
make a needle so I got one of my texts
to go up on the roof to measure how much
vitamin D you could make throughout the
year and we showed in Boston spring
summer and fall you make lots of vitamin
D and in wintertime can't make any at
all now my colleagues said you know what
we need evidence-based medicine and no
question my daughter who was up in
Vermont goes down to Florida for spring
break
yes you could make it year-round but
what about in the wintertime in Boston
and so to be convinced right we did
studies and show that if you live above
Atlanta Georgia you basically cannot
make any vitamin D in your skin from
about November through March so in
Europe if you think about this most of
Europe can't make vitamin D almost six
months of the year because of their high
latitude so what about making vitamin D
in the early morning or late afternoon
say living near the equator turns out
that we did a study with a group at
Saudi Arabia and showed that even at 18
degrees north that you don't begin
making any vitamin d2 about 9 10 o'clock
in the morning and it ends abruptly at 3
4 o'clock in the afternoon so yes can
you make vitamin D while jogging early
in the morning no it's good for romance
but you make no vitamin D only from 10
a.m. until 3 p.m. this is what we've
been talking about the Sun and no
question excessive exposure will damage
your skin increase risk for non melanoma
skin cancer so evolution think about
beach wear fifties the two-piece
seventies in one piece and new
millennium is now lots of sunscreen a
lot of clothing so what about vitamin D
and sunscreens and so we did a study and
asked the question
and showed that when you put whole body
there appropriate amount of sunscreen on
SPF of 30 reduces your ability to make
vitamin D and your skin by about 95
percent right 90 to 95 percent your
vitamin D is coming from sun exposure
how much every one a burn can't look
like this
and coming from New England of course
you can't look like that but we knew
exactly how long to stay outside and go
back into the shade when during early
evolution but we lost that ability about
10,000 years ago
so I carefully reviewed the literature
so you know how do you know when you
make enough vitamin D these little
poppies apart Valentin that doesn't
happen anymore
so we had a study and we asked the
question if you're exposed to one
minimum every single dose what is that
equivalent to and taking an oral dose of
vitamin D and we showed one minimal
erythema dose light Pinkus to your skin
24 hours later is equivalent to
ingesting about 20,000 units of vitamin
D so now you can understand our
hunter-gatherer forefathers outside
every day we're making thousands of
units of vitamin D about 15 to 20
percent of your body surface generate
about 1,500 to 2,000 units of vitamin D
why she's screaming we finally figured
it out because if you go on the internet
they tell you you should not bathe after
being and supposed to sunlight because
you're gonna wash off the precious
vitamin D not true you make it in your
living cells you don't wash it off so
yes please bathe if you've been sweating
outside in the Sun you will not wash off
your precious vitamin D so does it
provide you with your vitamin D
requirement here no matter what your
ethnicity even in Denmark they showed
the people as well was directly in the
summer and then Nader's at the end of
the winter
now what about aging and so we went on
to show many years ago the sims to
keeping up with the literature 75%
reduction but the skin is such a huge
capacity to make vitamin D is it
possible for him to make any at all and
so Ian Reed and we independently showed
that if you take elders and expose them
to sunlight they definitely will make
vitamin D so it is good for them to be
outside exposed to some sensible Sun so
these are all of the factors related to
vitamin D status but what about star
wars always coming out with these new
movies but the person I really enjoyed
the most was him and I always wondered
what he was thinking and now I know and
in fact even Barney was amazed he
vitamin D deficiency associated with
obesity indeed
the higher your BMI lower is your 25
hydroxy vitamin D and we did a study and
showed if you take normal weight and
obese individuals and give them the same
dose of vitamin D or expose them the
same amount of simulated sunlight they
only raise their blood level by about
45% evidence-based medicine we went to a
local bariatric surgeon and asked I need
some of your fat she said no problem doc
and we showed lots of vitamin D message
is simple obese people need 2 to 3 times
more vitamin D to satisfy that
requirement
what about gastric bypass surgery
they're losing 50 pounds of fat do they
mobilize that vitamin D and could you
become toxic so we did a study and
showed that in fact 20 oxy d levels
don't change at all as the fats being
destroyed so too is the vitamin D pehle
here with his girlfriend he has to be
outside of least four to ten times
longer because the skin pigment is a
natural sunscreen so is it true then
that people of color need much more
vitamin D an answer is no they just need
the same amount which is recommended by
the endocrine Society
how do you know your vitamin D status
Doc's have been wondering about this and
of course what you want to measure is 25
hydroxy vitamin D and the normal range
is usually 20 to 100 but actually ducks
don't have the time to look at numbers
is that H is at N or is it L and so
typically at the end of the summer
patients will come back from Cape Cod
with an H and my primary care Doc's
would friends would call me up and say
my patients vitamin D toxic what do I do
and I say not really I don't see the bay
lunch babies in my clinic but we do see
some lifeguards there at least 110
nanograms per ml or they toxic I don't
think so you don't have to worry about
intoxication - you're over 150 nanograms
for mo what about the lower limit that's
what you should care about and so is
there evidence that you should be above
thirty one of the studies that was done
with and the PAP showed that if you look
at all throughout the United States
postmenopausal women and looking after
25 hydroxy vitamin D
eh levels they begin to plateau at
around 30 they had a to three times
higher risk of developing secondary
hyperparathyroidism when they were 21
compared to greater than 30 why do some
patients have low 20 oxy d with normal
PTH and so is it possible that there's a
seasonal change in both and we did a
study and we looked at quest Diagnostics
data set 3.8 million samples and showed
that at the time that the PTH Peaks in
the winter time 2008 vitamin D nadir is
four weeks earlier and vice versa so PTH
Peaks four weeks later in response to 25
at Roxy D so if you're not ordering PTH
basically at the same time of the peak
or nadir of 2008 OCD it makes it
difficult to interpret it but in Mon
Jordan which I came back they have
higher peak levels in the summer but it
turns out that even in Elana Georgia
type of latitude with these 3.8 million
samples
yes females were a little bit better
than males because they have exposed a
little bit more skin but what's amazing
is that the peak blood level living down
southern United States is that no
different than living in the northern
United States so living in Amman Jordan
for example didn't make any difference
and so August was about 27 nanograms per
ml for the peak so never even reached
that 30 nanograms which is what is
recommended by the endocrine Society
also this IOM had recommended that only
needed 20 nanograms 4 ml for maximum
bone cells and this is based on this
study of 675 German adults ages 20 to 90
that died in an unfortunate accident
their blood and their bone was collected
and as you could see on this side good
normal trabecular bone here you see
hardly any at all consistent with
osteoporosis but here you see the black
area but also the pink area and that
pink area is accumulated osteoid classic
for vitamin D deficiency
and even internal in the bone as well
and they showed that about 26.5% of
otherwise German healthy adults had
evidence of vitamin D deficiency bone
disease and so the Institute of Medicine
said well if you take this over this
only about 1% had evidence of
osteomalacia so you only need to be at
20 but what they should have done was as
suggested by the authors is that you
take this over this 24 percent of
otherwise healthy German adults between
21 and 29 nanograms for ML had evidence
of vitamin D deficiency bone disease and
this is the reason why the endocrine
society came out with its
recommendations and because of some of
the vagaries of the assays that are out
there that you'll be hearing more about
by one of the other speakers we
recommend 40 to 60 as a preferred range
up to a hundred is perfectly safe is
vitamin D deficient a health issue no
question in the United States the CDC
reported 32 percent of children and
adults at risk
indeed worldwide basically forty percent
of the population is deficient 60%
deficient or insufficient UAE one of the
world's highest vitamin D deficiency
because they don't take advantage of
sensible sun exposure and they
essentially have no dietary vitamin D
eighty-six percent were deficient were
insufficient also wearing this type of
clothing definitely can increase risk
and it's another cause for vitamin D
deficiency in the Middle East newborns
in Amman Jordan ninety four percent were
deficient conclusion prevalence of
severe vitamin D deficiency is a problem
and if vitamin D supplementation is
needed for probably most populations as
I had mentioned before 94 percent
division right vitamin D supplementation
is essential for pregnant women and
newborns vitamin D deficiency also
precipitates and exacerbates
osteoporosis and so the issue has been
does it really reduce or increase risk
of fractures and deconstructing vite
indeed efficiency here you see very nice
healthy bone and here you see all the
porosity due to vitamin D deficiency and
vitamin D deficiency increases early
signs of aging in human bone very nice
study that was done showing normal vs.
vitamin D deficient all of these dark
red lines are actually cracks in the
bones associated with vitamin D
deficiency increasing risk for fragility
of that skeleton and fracture so
osteoporosis silent disease but
osteomalacia is not so silent
indeed symptoms are generalized bone
pain isolated bone pain muscle aches and
pains Nuvo diagnosis fibromyalgia turns
out that most of these patients I see in
my clinic are vitamin D deficient and
have dramatic improvement in their
symptoms correcting their vitamin D
deficiency also even growing pains and
children have been associated with
vitamin D deficiency here at the Mayo
Clinic proceedings they showed of 150
children ounce presenting with aches and
pains of their bones and muscles 93
percent were vitamin D deficient this
classic 23 year old female shows up in
the emergency department weakness
fatigue and non radicular pain - sign me
up being depressed is the diagnosis and
says sent home agent female same thing
with black male he Luck's out because
he's went up on a narcotic sent home
they were all on vitamin D deficient 78
year old male shows up with muscle
weakness atrophied denervation
positive EMG nerve conduction study for
ALS but also that patient was vitamin D
deficient corrected the D deficiency all
symptoms resolved because progressive
payments muscle weakness with muscle
atrophy that manifests like motor neuron
disease improves after vitamin D
supplementation in FD new steroids
because vitamin D deficiency causes
proximal muscle weakness and improvement
in your vitamin D status improves muscle
function in part because you have a
vitamin D receptor in your skeletal
muscle so either wonder where Superman
gets a strength from there's no question
about it
that vitamin D is critically important
for a muscle
strength indeed very nicely shows
vitamin D is good for muscle strength we
did a study and others have done similar
studies and this study here done in
Europe showed that physical performance
especially even in older adults is
maximum when the blood level is greater
than about thirty nanograms per ml we
did a study at a nursing home and showed
72 percent lower risk of falling just on
eight hundred units of vitamin d a day
and no benefit on these lower doses so
he's constant complaining to his dog
about aches and pains and his bones and
muscles and this dog told him stupid
your vitamin D deficient right so we
want you to be at least thirty maximize
your bone health maximize muscle
function less likely to fall less likely
to fracture so how do you treat it well
what you want to do take a multivitamin
but you already could take one of these
because otherwise you're gonna choke on
them and you had to get too much vitamin
A so you're taking on empty get a gallon
of gas No and so what you want to do
we've treat fifty thousand units of
vitamin d2 once a week for eight weeks
why vitamin d2 it's the only one
available as a pharmaceutical in the
United States because it predates the
FDA no one has ever gotten the approval
or as a pharmaceutical form of vitamin
d3 pharmacies are getting from
supplement manufacturers fifty thousand
units of vitamin d3 but it's not
pharmaceutical grade once a week for
eight weeks equivalent about sixty five
hundred units a day and then to prevent
recurrence I put them on 50,000 units
every two weeks forever equivalent to
about three thousand three hundred units
a day but you're worried are they gonna
build this up in their body so we did a
study and showed after six years on
equivalent of fifty thousand every two
weeks or three thousand units a day is
effective in maintaining normal vitamin
D status even the endocrine guidelines
show fifty thousand twice a month will
maintain levels around thirty five to
fifty nanograms for ML also no question
about it
why is it here on end do we need to
screening everybody and so it turns out
that no because we showed many years ago
50,000 units twice a month for all
comers coming to my clinic that even if
they were starting out of 50 the highest
irrigating was 18 anagrams per ml so we
don't need to screen everybody so r2d2
the worried but d2 is it less effective
than c-3po or d3 and so we went to the
mythbusters and we did a study and we
showed thousand units of d3 versus a
thousand units of d2 pacy bo d3 d2 no
difference in blood levels indeed we
also showed a thousand units a day to
help the adults in the wintertime in
Boston will not maintain a level above
30 nanograms per ml no question about
this right vitamin D toxicity people
worry about all the time it's elevated
calcium and elevated 25 hydroxy D Bob
Guiney and us showed 10,000 units a day
is perfectly safe study done in Canada
pure in North groups show 20,000 units a
day to some adults was perfectly fine
what about children and infants study
was done by Catherine Gordon at
Children's Hospital 2,000 units a day to
treat the deficiency is perfectly fine
what about pregnant women boost hollows
the Carroll Wagner showed 4,000 units a
day blood level on average 50 nanograms
per ml no change in serum calcium and
urinary calcium indeed you can become
toxic because a gentleman called me from
Florida a lawyer and he said he wanted
to sue me because back in the 1990's
I was already encouraging people to take
2,000 units of vitamin D a day in the
United States back in the 90s you
couldn't find a vitamin D supplement so
he went on the internet and he bought
this product
thou's unison TSP he took two teaspoons
a day I told him look before you sue me
send the stuff up would do an analysis
for you and we did the company forgot to
dilute it he was actually taking a
million units a day of pure crystalline
vitamin D this will cause intoxication
he had a counselor 1525 CD of 500
it's difficult to become vitamin D toxic
so why should you care about all this
because once you make vitamin D in your
skin of course it goes to your liver and
then to your kidneys to get activated
and yes your calcium regulating tissues
have a vitamin D receptor but over the
past two decades many investigators have
shown that every tissue and cell in your
body has a vitamin D receptor why would
they be there if they weren't having an
effect
the earliest observation was made by
Sudha back in 1979 leukemic cells had a
vitamin d receptor incubate them with
active vitamin D they became normal so
what about the vitamin D in cancer
connection turns out a lot of evidence
linking sunlight deficiency and vitamin
D deficiency with increased risk back in
1915 it was shown that if you worked
indoors you had a 15-8 fold higher
likelihood of dying than living outside
and working outside as these sailors are
also sunbathing can cut your risk of
cancer 1941 I was shown you live in the
Northeast you're more likely to die in
cancer than if you live down south and
the garland brothers showed in 2005 50%
lower with colorectal cancer just being
on a thousand units of vitamin D a day
Nurses Health Study showed very nicely
nurses that had the highest blood levels
you would have to be taking about 3 to
4,000 units a day reduce risk of breast
cancer by 50%
also Bob Heaney's group showed that if
the postmenopausal women who started out
at 13 anagrams for ml and took an
additional thousand units of vitamin D a
day reduce risk of all cancers by 60% in
four years possible connection well you
may argue ah
this all makes sense because the kidneys
if you get more vitamin D they're gonna
make more of the active form it's an
anti-cancer agent it bathes all of your
body turns out yes activated vitamin D
and Hibbert's cancer cell growth but no
matter how much vitamin D you ingest you
can't raise your blood level of 125
dihydroxy vitamin D because it's
responsible for regulating calcium
metabolism
that was a real conundrum and it turns
out we asked the question would Gary
Schwartz and others did a very similar
type of study is it possible other cells
have the capacity to activate vitamin D
and sure enough we went on to show that
not only prostate but Colin and even
brain shown by dr. York Reich rock have
the ability to activate vitamin D
regulate a whole host of genes and then
a cleverly destroys itself so that it
can't have any impact on calcium
metabolism estimated up to 2,000 genes
directly or indirectly regulated by the
active form of vitamin D so what about
your immune system turns out activated
macrophages activate vitamin D why it's
actually pretty simple a very nice study
done in California by Marlon and Adams
and Louvre showed yes cod liver oil and
TB flight of a deep protects against TB
why because they published a paper
showing that macrophages when ingesting
an infectious agent like TB total egg
receptors are turned on why to tell the
cell to activate vitamin D why it then
tells the cell to make cthulhu sidon
it's a defense and protein that
specifically kills infectious agents so
that's why solariums and living at
higher altitudes was so effective in
helping to treat and prevent TB
infection with the flu season coming in
a winter time hope Simpson had suggested
there's a seasonal stimulus well at the
peak flu season is that the blood levels
of your 25 knock CD are at their lowest
and so a study was done in New Haven
Connecticut showing that adults would a
level around 38 nanograms for ML reduce
risk of upper respiratory tract
infections twofold
a study done in Japan showed
schoolchildren 1200 units of vitamin D a
data in the wintertime reduce risk of
influenza infection by about 42%
diabetes the higher the latitude that
you live higher is your
risk for developing type 1 diabetes
indeed it was shown in a study out of
Finland opponent followed children who
had received 2,000 units of vitamin D a
day in the 1960s for 31 years showed
that if they were on 2,000 units of
vitamin D a day for their first year of
life reduce risk of type 1 diabetes by
88 percent right look at this they
started decreasing the vitamin D intake
in Finland because they're worried about
toxicity now look at the incidence of
type 1 diabetes on the rise
what about other evidence your beta
islet cells have a vitamin D receptor
and active vitamin D stimulates insulin
production and potage showed many years
ago from the National Health Survey the
higher your calcium and vitamin D intake
33 percent lower risk of developing type
2 diabetes multiple sclerosis again
living above that magical latitude of
about 33 or 35 degrees if you live above
that latitude for the first 10 years of
your life 100% increased risk of
developing multiple sclerosis for the
rest of your life study done again
Nurses Health Study showed women taking
more than 400 units a day reduce risk of
MS 41% and rheumatoid arthritis out of a
study out of Iowa 44% osteoarthritis has
been associated with vitamin D
deficiency peripheral vascular disease
from the National survey showed 80%
lower risk
if your level is at least 30 nanograms
per ml also Zimmerman showed nicely
heart failure associated mechanism up to
200 genes in the cardiovascular system
regulating out there sclerotic
production blood pressure control and
heart function
indeed in circulation Framingham Heart
Study showed if your levels around 15
nanograms or lower 50 percent higher
risk of having a heart attack also it's
been suggested if you take your calcium
supplement you're at increased risk but
a nice study out of Nurses Health Study
showed almost 75,000 and women 29%
reduction in cardiovascular disease for
those who took their calcium and vitamin
D what are they thinking about tell you
what
teens are at risk the national health
survey showed up to 50 million teens
higher blood pressure and elevated blood
sugar and metabolic syndrome we did a
study with dr. dong in Georgia and
showed when we gave teenage
african-american boys and girls 2,000
units of vitamin D a day just for a few
months it reduced arterial wall
stiffness kind of the prelude to
hypertension if that doesn't get your
attention this might all studies have
shown if you increase your vitamin D
intake you are less likely to die indeed
here at a Germany 25 percent all cause
mortality reduction and Garlin showed 40
to 50 nanograms four ml is your maximum
effect and even out to 70 and greater
that you continue to have that benefit
of reduced mortality is there any other
evidence on the immune system well
ultimately your genes know and so we did
a study and we took eight adults and we
gave them vitamin D and did a chip
analysis all of these blue lines are
under expressed and all of these yellow
and orange are overexpressed genes we
found just giving them 2,000 units of
vitamin D a day altered 291 genes and
about 80 different processes including
DNA repair apoptosis oxidative stress as
well as other factors feed your genes
right with vitamin D right and so what
about maintaining your blood levels
vitamin D itself seems to be able to
stabilize endothelial membranes so
vitamin D itself independent of 25lakhs
CD may have its own benefit and in worms
given them vitamin D showed that it
prevented age-related accumulation of
proteins that are responsible for the
aging process adequate vitamin D is
critically important from birth until
death and so vitamin D deficiency is a
disease of neglect in fact there's a
mountain of evidence linking it to these
chronic illnesses so don't think about a
normal level but a healthy level we want
everybody to be at around
42:16 nanograms per ml just like them
they would need to be ingesting four to
five thousand units a day if they
weren't outside every day goal should be
at least thirty forty to sixty is
preferred it's a major health issue with
a variety of issues in terms of disease
burden indeed how much do you need for
every hundred units you ingest when
you're blevells around 20 nanograms four
ml you raise it by one nanogram per ml
so if you're in this range and I
guarantee that you are if you're not
taking a supplement a thousand units a
day will not make an animal sufficient
right
I recommend minimum two thousand for
adults thousand for children
Concord D deficiency best source bond
bred back in the 30s they advertised if
you didn't want your kids naked outside
every day eat vitamin D fortified bond
bread I know young adults would not be d
deficient if they were still doing this
because back in the 1930s beer was
fortified with vitamin D and indeed I
went on eBay and bought a can FDA did
not take kindly to drinking beer and
have any nutritional benefit so they
forbid that advertisement in 1937
look Johnny aspire sunshine and playing
to get your vitamin D we've always known
about the healthful benefits of the Sun
how do you get the message out so I
naive we wrote a book in 2004 and I
pointed out I don't advocate tanning and
that yes excessive exposure will
increase risk for non melanoma skin
cancer but everybody worries about
melanoma most melanomas occur on the
least Sun exposed areas and occupational
sun exposure actually decreases risk and
there are the data lifetime sun exposure
associated with a lower risk of
malignant melanoma general investigative
dermatology 2003 ancestors view a little
bit different than what the
dermatologists think about the Sun
indeed they tell you always wear sun
protection never be exposed to one
direct ray of sunlight have you ever
been on rounds went online
dermatologists
they definitely recommend no sun
exposure
I like the kinder gentler view in life
and Schultz epitomizes this and his
penis character - getting no from his
mom are you seeing in the Sun I hope so
a little Sun is good as long as when
overdo it perhaps ten minutes a day this
time of the year is about right he was
right on target indeed this is what's
happened to our son it's been demonized
for more than 40 years right subscribe
stop message in Australia 40 percent of
Australians are now deficient who's that
that's Australian dermatologists on
vacation and they measured their vitamin
D status 87% were vitamin D deficient at
the end of the summer also your brain as
a vitamin D receptor it responds to
vitamin D by increasing serotonin levels
it's been associated with schizophrenia
depression and dementia even Alzheimer's
disease has been associated with vitamin
D deficiency so many of these chronic
CNS illnesses have been related to
vitamin D deficiency but what about the
other issue what about skin cancer and
sun damage so a very nice study was
recently done by Felton and colleagues
concur and beneficial effect of vitamin
D production and then looking at DNA
damage and they did this over a period
of about six weeks simulating sunlight
in Great Britain for both white and
people with increased skin pigment photo
type 2 skin type 215 nanograms for ml's
what they started and after six weeks
raised 221 nanograms for ML type 5 very
dark skin pigment only barely if any
raise our blood level what about DNA
damage they went out to show before
no DNA damage and yes one week after
exposure all those black dots are DNA
damage less into type 5 but after six
weeks there's a reduction in the amount
of DNA damage because there are now
repair mechanisms involved
basically you can essentially have your
cake and eat a to some sensible sun
exposure will not have significant
damage to your skin but it's really not
possible with our lifestyles right you
can't be exposed to sunlight from 10
a.m. to 3 p.m. for at least 30 40
percent of your body surface and that's
why yes sensible sun exposure helps you
with your vitamin D status but you
definitely need to think about taking a
supplement because can you get it from
your diet and the answer is no and so
what do I do well the best source is
sunlight but time of day season latitude
degree of skin pigmentation so what to
do it's the only one thing to do develop
an app which we did and so it's free on
your iPhone and Android the minder dot
info it will tell you anyone on this
planet any time of the year how much
vitamin D you can make and it wants you
to get out of the Sun so you don't get a
sunburn sunscreen on my face but not on
my arms and legs and I like all my
family members take about 4,000 units of
vitamin D a day blood level 16 nanograms
per ml right no question we can get some
vitamin D from the Sun but we still need
to take a supplement and that's the
message right vitamin D deficiency is
one of the most common medical
conditions worldwide
if any one of these chronic illnesses
turn out to be associated with vitamin D
deficiency there is no downside to
increasing your vitamin D intake right
you don't need to be a genius to know
this we need sensible Sun and for
vitamin D fortification programs and
supplement recommendations this is not a
hypothesis should you be screening
everybody I hopefully have convinced you
now that most people in my clinic we
give them 50,000 years of vitamin D
every two weeks or equivalent of taking
two to 3,000 units a day for adults a
thousand units for children but if
you're obese if you have malabsorption
problems if you're on medications like
google corticoids that alter vitamin D
metabolism or sarcoidosis where you have
a hypersensitivity then yes you've got
to follow these patients carefully
I've written a new book called the
vitamin D solution and recommendation
from the endocrine society infants four
hundred to a thousand units adults
fifteen hundred to two thousand
teenagers in my opinion should be
treated like adults but younger children
six hundred to a thousand units is
perfectly safe and if you're obese two
to three times more indeed the safe
upper limit easily for infants to
thousands a day easily for children for
thousands a day and as the Endocrine
Society recommends up to ten thousand
units a day is perfectly safe vitamin D
can help improve your health and I hope
that you have found this to be helpful
and I encourage you to get some sensible
Sun and take adequate vitamin D to
satisfy your vitamin D requirement and
thank you for your attention